en fait khatera ça devait faire santé
jeudi matin à l'institut national du
sport
c'est l'atelier cuisine de la
nutritionniste en résidence
eve crépeau de des recettes proposées ou
trampolinistes son vegan dont le pouding
au riz riz brun bien sûr le végétalisme
ou véganisme connaît un essor croissant
au sein de la communauté des athlètes
d'élite
oui je remarque de plus en plus
d'athlètes qui vont aller végétales
j'en ai quelques-uns c'est tout si le
choix qu'a fait le triathlète antoine
jolicoeur des roches d'abord végétarien
il est devenu 100% vegan il y a cinq ans
pour des raisons éthiques
c'est vraiment le fun car ce qui
démontre vraiment les parcs de de
l'industrie alimentaire les vaches le
lait le fromage sur l'environnement que
je dessinais de devenir complètement
vrai talent et la vague déferle partout
en octobre l'équipe suédoise de ski
alpin a décidé de bannir tout produit
animal de son menu préoccupé par son
empreinte carbone et par la fonte des
glaciers où elle s'entraîne
chez les professionnels aussi le
véganisme à la cote du pilote
britannique lewis hamilton aux soeurs
williams en passant par le cor arrière
des patriots de la nouvelle angleterre
tom brady qui devra d'ailleurs fermé les
yeux sur les quelque 700 millions de
poulets dont les ailes seront dévoilés
pendant le super bowl
on retrouve maintenant des vegan dans
tous les sports oui mais où
impressionnant les sports d'endurance
dont la course à pied les traqueront les
gens pensaient pas qu'un espoir vraiment
de force comme latéraux fini d eux mêmes
de la boxe qu'on pourrait le véritable
performer mais de plus en plus on voit
ça dans dans les eaux fc dans les
maisons martiaux dans la bosse en raison
de leur grande dépense énergétique les
athlètes vegan ont tous la même bête
noire souvent il faut inquiet par
rapport à leurs protéines estime en
avoir assez de protéines